Lose control in the new year i went from dying
to being more alive than ever it worked not
exactly i have increased strength and speed
and some form of bad radar what else can i do
In the film version of morbius that we're
bringing to you now he's also a part of
a much larger universe if you've seen the
last spider-man no way home trailer you know
the multiverse has officially opened and there's
all kinds of opportunities for villains to meet up
thrive and maybe even nurture their more sinister
intents that's all i'm gonna say for right now
Happy new year everyone this will be my new
morbius trailer video jared leto doing everything
he can to tell you that this is connected
to spider-man no way home the multiverse
and there's going to be a big sinister
six and spider-man crossover in the movie
there are also a lot of you that are asking
now about andrew garfield easter eggs is this
happening in the amazing spider-man universe
the morbius movie because there's so many easter
eggs pointing to his character and call backs
to amazing spider-man 2 that i'll talk about
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos the morbius
movie is coming out at the end of this month and
thankfully it doesn't sound like it's going to
be delayed in any countries like spider-man no way
home was delayed in a couple places but i will say
careful for spoilers for spider-man no way home
because we have to talk about what happened with
all the multiverse characters during that and how
it connects to the morbius movie but a lot of you
saw the last few morbia's trailer videos and you
saw spider-man no way home with andrew garfield
and toby mcguire coming back along with the
multiverse sinister six characters and wondered if
the morbius movie is actually happening in andrew
garfield's amazing spider-man universe of movies
there are some tobey maguire spider-man references
and easter eggs in the trailer like the tobey
maguire spider-man suit with the tom holland
mysterio plot points the version of the daily
bugle newspaper that morbius is reading is the
tobey maguire version with the daily bugle logos
from his films and even though the building
looks a little bit different the version of
ozcorp is the andrew garfield amazing spider-man
version and the daily bugle mentions the rhino the
black cat characters who were both characters in
amazing spider-man 2. if you don't remember there
were some deleted scenes with felicia hardy she
was eventually going to turn into a version of
black cat like they had a felicia hardy assistant
at oscorp but she had not become black cat yet
that would have been a big amazing spider-man
3 moment so i will reference amazing spider-man
3 because there were a lot of references to that
during spider-man no way home and it sounds like
here during the morbius trailer if it's been
a while since you've seen amazing spider-man
2 during that movie you might remember they
referenced morbius and venom specifically along
with a bunch of other teasers for other characters
and things buried in harry osborne's oscorp files
like zoom and enhance here they have a morbius
project that they were working on they had a venom
project so had they made amazing spider-man
3 with andrew garfield they would have given
him the venom symbiote during that movie and he
would have faced a version of the sinister six
as they teased in the post-credits scene but we
also would have seen a version of black cat show
up and then obviously they were trying to set
up a whole bunch of other spin-off movies too
now that andrew garfield has come back in a big
way during spider-man no way home as a multiverse
spider-man spider-verse spider-man however you
want to think about him along with toby maguire
now everyone's wondering which version of
spider-man we're actually going to see them
lean on during the morbius movie because very
clearly he's trying to say that this is all
connected to spiderman no way home so all the
stuff that's happening with tom holland's mcu
spider-man andrew garfield spider-man toby
maguire spider-man it's all connected like
they have the tobii mcguire suit in the trailer
so clearly everyone in more beast's universe
knows about a version of spider-man they're
calling out spider-man and all the daily bugle
advertisements on all these buses but before the
venom leatherby carnage post-credit scene in the
spider-man no way home post-credit scenes i'd
assume that because sony was making the morbius
in the venom movies they would just say that
those characters came from the same universe
and we just see them cross over with a version
of tom holland's mcu spider-man in some way
all the stuff they gave us during spider-man
no way home with all the different versions of
spider-man was way crazier than i ever would have
imagined so now theories just got way way bigger
during the trailer footage jared leto literally
references spider-man no way home the multiverse
in the sinister six we know there'll be some
kind of morbius spider-man crossover when he
says that's all i'll say for now i think that just
means that he's going to have his own version of
that venom let the be carnage post credit scene
where we see him either cross over with the mcu
or where he sees a version of spider-man crosses
over with him some spider-man crossover in some
kind of way they kind of had to change the order
of the post-credits scenes just a little bit
because the order that they've released the movies
in has changed because of the virus but here's the
thing during that spider-man no way home post
credit scene venom got teleported back to his
original universe from the mcu by doctor strange's
second spell even though he does leave a piece of
the symbiote behind so they can do a version
of an mcu venom with tom hall and spider-man
in the future but during the movie andrew
garfield referenced what sounded like a teaser
for the venom symbiote saga in his own universe
like he talked about being bitter and angry after
gwen stacy died becoming rageful not pulling his
punches anymore that to me sounds like the setup
for an andrew garfield symbiote saga as if he
was explaining the plot of amazing spider-man 3
and that's also kind of why they called him peter
3. like tom holland was peter 1 toby maguire was
peter 2 andrew garfield called himself peter 3 as
a sort of wink at amazing spider-man 3. so because
there's all these easter eggs and references
mostly tying morbius to andrew garfield spider-man
and it sounds like they had a plan a long time ago
to introduce a version of morbius in the amazing
spider-man universe it's always possible that sony
brings andrew garfield's spider-man back for more
cameos as part of the continuing sort of morbius
venom universe that they're building over on
their side of things we do have michael keaton's
vulture so like there is stuff tying him to mcu
tom hall and spider-man i'll talk about that in a
second because that gets into the new version of
the sinister six they're putting together with a
different roster the writers of spider-man no way
home did say that they had originally wanted to
do post-credit scenes for toby maguire and andrew
garfield to tease what these versions of the
characters would be doing next after the end of
the film and there has been talk about bringing
the characters back in future movies more so
andrew garfield i think that toby mcguire just
based on the way toby came back to the project
he was the last to sign on and even though he
was totally down for everything they did with the
character andrew garfield stole every scene that
he was in and just seemed like he enjoyed being
back as the character way way more and that he
would be down to continue doing that in the future
just based on what the writer said as for the
version of the sinister six that jared leto
referenced at the beginning of this in the clip
that i attached to the video the report last year
before spider-man no way home came out was that
during the movie michael keaton's vulture is being
held at the same prison that morbius eventually
gets sent to and because this is in an alternate
universe it is a variant of mcu vulture but when
morbius eventually transforms and escapes vulture
also escapes but as they cross past here in this
scene as he says hey let's stay in touch in the
full version of the scene supposedly michael
keaton's vulture tells morbius that he's putting
together a team and that's meant to be a teaser
for the next version of the sinister six like
we kind of got a multiverse version of the team
during spider-man no way home but there were only
five of them like venom was in the post-credits
scene and the writers did say they had a plan to
put venom in the final battle so venom would
have been the sixth sinister six character
but at the end of the movie they all get sent back
to where they came from so when they do a legit
spider-man vs sinister six movie like all six
of them together the roster has to be different
and it just sounds like from the morbius trailer
footage here the vulture will lead the team
he'll put it together and they might include rhino
and black cat because of the daily bugle easter
eggs here we still have a version of scorpion in
the mcu there's a version of mysterio that's still
out there if they want to bring him back and we
just learned about the craven the hunter movie
that they're doing with aaron taylor johnson can't
wait to see all the quicksilver variant memes when
that movie comes out and you also have to remember
at the end of spider-man no way home there's the
teaser for that big multiverse scene when reality
cracks open there's all these big tears in reality
and you see those shining figures appear they're
mostly other multiverse versions of sinister
six characters there's a version of kraven the
hunter with his spear there's a classic version
of the scorpion there's a version of black cat a
classic version of the rhino and another version
of mysterio there's even a superior spider-man in
here too there are hundreds of other characters
that appear here but those are just the ones
that i could spot without having an hd copy of
the movie that i can zoom and enhance on but some
of those sinister six characters that appeared in
the cracks are the ones that they reference in
the morpheus trailer so it sounds like at least
some of them will be part of the next roster when
michael keaton's vulture puts the team together
and we could see andrew garfield come back for
that movie when they do it originally when andrew
garfield was still playing the main version
of spider-man sony did have plans for a whole
separate sinister six solo franchise like they
would do some sinister six in amazing spider-man 3
but then also do a separate spin-off sinister
six movie franchise now that they're coming back
around and it seems like they're doing all the
movies that they had originally planned on doing
just with a couple different actors they might
do the same thing again with spider-man versus
sinister six movies but then also separate
sinister six solo movies so there are just
many many opportunities out there to bring andrew
garfield's spider-man back i think part of the
idea in going so big with the multiverse with the
spider-verse and all these different live-action
versions of spider-man is so that it's easier
for them to use different versions of spider-man
in some of these movies it doesn't always
have to be tom hall and spider-man because
practically speaking that would get expensive
and tom han probably isn't going to want to make
25 different spider-man movies i know i only
mentioned black cat in rhino easter eggs in the
morbius movie but there's also some craven easter
eggs that they don't show in the trailer but that
we did see on the set so version of craven is also
inside the morbius universe already but i know a
lot of you are also asking will andrew garfield or
toby maguire spider-man have cameo scenes during
dr strange multiverse of madness because it seems
like there are so many x-men easter eggs they're
introducing in that and we just had spider-man no
way home it's always possible i'm not expecting
them to cameo but it is possible most of the
cameos i think will be alternate versions of
mcu characters like all the different variants
of doctor strange that i've already talked about
in my trailer videos but also a bunch of x-men
cameo scenes as well that's really i think the big
selling point like okay we gave you spider-verse
and spider-man no way home now we're bringing back
some of those classic x-men characters but post
all your theories about andrew garfield coming
back in future movies toby maguire coming back
they are doing a disney plus spider-man series but
it's actually a prequel series for tom holland's
mcu spider-man i'll do videos for that but we
won't see it for a couple years but everyone
click here for my full doctor strange multiverse
of madness trailer video and easter eggs and
click here to learn how they changed all the
timelines of the tobey maguire spider-man movies
and the andrew garfield spider-man movies during
spider-man no way home thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!